anthony came on because he's just so
amazing and such a sweetheart
and so we had so much fun just like
hanging out in the studio and recording
it on the weekend
and you know practicing and then like
you know performing it was just it was
such a great experience overall
i really think people are gonna like the
dynamic that
victor and raheen have because i mean i
am a little biased but i
i love the dynamic that they have and i
think they're really great for each
other
[Music]
first off congratulations i've seen
all of love victor season two and you
just completely
shine as rahim did you know much about
the character before you
landed the role like what did you know
going into it when you heard about this
audition
when i got the call that season two was
starting up and that casting
i really only got the breakdown which
was
at first the character's name was cyrus
and it's an osiris-16
student at creekwood queer at the start
of his coming out journey
iranian-american and i was like
okay i can work with this i can
definitely work with this you know
i think knows who he is completely and
knows what he wants
it was just a matter of figuring out how
to vocalize that and to be
that but yeah i definitely think that
raheem and victor
are on the same wavelength
watching victor and raheem sing karaoke
at the gay bar a season highlight for me
michael
what was that like for you and and i
didn't know you could sing
yeah yeah it was it was really exciting
because you know i didn't really get to
explore it i haven't really put out any
music yet but it is coming out soon so
music is coming it is on the way
it was really cool to be able to like
mix two of my passions together at the
same time and
like be able to sing and also like
you know go to the studio with my friend
anthony like anthony came on because
he's just so amazing and such a
sweetheart and so we had so much fun
just like hanging out in the studio and
recording it on the weekend and you know
practicing and then like
you know performing it was just it was
such a great experience overall
it was so much fun i mean probably one
of my highlights of
filming the season it was really
nerve-wracking for me because i
michael has a musical background and i
knew that he would be able to carry it
if i couldn't and going into it i was
like
aha i don't know like i went into the
recording studio
and we you know rehearsed a couple of
times
and i kind of got a little bit warmed up
and
it ended up being really really good not
to toot my own horn or anything
but i'm really impressed i think it's
gonna like top spotify i really do
that would be awesome but that was
definitely one of my favorite scenes as
well i really had a good time shooting
that
and recording the song like it was it
was a dream it was really fun
you taught me everything i know about
being brave and who knows
maybe one day i can inspire someone to
be themselves the same way you inspired
me
i loved the fact that you know obviously
victor has always reached out to
simon for advice and we got a sincerely
raheem
moment which was so sweet and and just
so full circle
to see victor kind of play the mentor
role instead of the mentee
and to kind of bring that around what
did that mean for you
it was really cool to see that shift in
victor
kind of like the student becomes a
teacher kind of a thing
i just thought it was really cool that
he was able to you know learn from his
own experiences and provide a little bit
of guidance
for someone else who could be going
through the same thing and that's really
what the show is all about
and i'm i was really excited to get to
to tell
the same story but different you know we
got some really great bonding scenes
between victor and a new character
raheem
and they have a really great friendship
and might evolve into something else who
knows
um but they had some really great
connections about what it's like to be
a gay minority teen these days what did
that mean for you to be able to have
these characters share that connection
i think that you know people of color
definitely do face different challenges
when they
are coming out they do face this barrier
where it's like you know it's been
taught to them that they are
usually more religious and so basically
they have to kind of like push through
this barrier to like
accept their children and i feel like
you know a lot of white families it
could be very different obviously there
are very
like christian and catholic white
families as well but i do feel like
people of color do face
different adversity because of also like
the stigma of being masculine and you
have to
be masculine and you have to stick up
for yourself and you have to be strong
enough to support your family because
of all that you know stuff so i think
that it is
it is like really important to like kind
of discuss that there is a difference
between being white
and gay and also being brown or a person
of color and being gay i don't want to
be a secret anymore because
i'm happy about it i definitely think
that there should be more stories told
for people of color who are part of the
lgbtq plus community
and to be kind of like one of the first
is really really really cool because
it's one thing to see
people of color portraying queer stories
and characters but it's another thing to
see
you know people of like the muslim
islamic background portraying a person
who is lgbtq plus because that's
something that's like
forbidden in in those cultures you know
i've been getting
dms from people who are like me you know
iranian kids and stuff like they're just
like
thank you for this and i think it's
really really special and i'm just so
grateful to be that for someone i was
totally like
team venji heading into the season and
then seeing all their ups and downs and
realizing like
just because you have a swoon worthy
first kiss doesn't mean that the
relationship is going to be smooth
sailing
and so i was really taken by the ease
that raheem and victor really have
together how do you think the fans are
going to react
i definitely think the fans are probably
going to be a little shocked
because i've already seen like the
comments they're like oh i hope this guy
doesn't come in between
victor and benji you're like don't judge
it because i come in real smooth
yeah i think they're going to be a
little shocked because you know victor
has been trying so hard with ng
throughout season one and season two but
that's what makes good tv right
twist returns but i really do think
that people will see the side of rahim
and that he didn't mean to you know
get in between them it just kind of sort
of happened and that's what a beautiful
love story is
where it just falls into place and
there's no work really involved
so i'm hoping for the best
but i think i really think people are
going to like the dynamic that
victor and raheem have because i mean i
am a little biased but
i i love the dynamic that they have and
i think they're really great for each
other
what is their ship name i've been
thinking about that um i guess it would
be like richter
richter is good raheem ooh that sounds a
little like vagine never mind
i think i mean veggie doesn't
necessarily sound
that pleasing yeah
let's go it's just how shift names go